und das musste ja irgendwann kommen
russland reduziert gaslieferungen durch
die nord stream pipeline um 40 prozent
ja welche auswirkungen das dann sofort
auf die energieversorgung hier bei uns
in deutschland hat dazu gibt es noch
keine angaben bislang hat es aber immer
geheißen dass kurzfristige engpässe mit
den vorhandenen reserven kompensiert
werden können wir sprechen darüber mit
wirtschaftswissenschaftlerinnen
professorin claudia kempfert hallo
vorkämpfers hallo ich grüße sie wer wird
unser gas jetzt ganz plötzlich knapp
nein knapp wird es ganz plötzlich nicht
wir sind ja in den sommermonaten da ist
die nachfrage ohnehin gering geringer
als zumindest auch im winter im moment
geht es eher darum die speicher zu
füllen die in deutschland etwa 55
prozent der gefüllt sind und das kann
gegebenenfalls jetzt er verzögert werden
man hat ja sowieso kürzlich angekündigte
die nord stream pipeline zu warten da
ging es darum dass im juli zwei wochen
die gar kein gas durch noch so im einzel
fließen wird auch da ist die
gasversorgung gesichert also darauf ist
man durchaus auch vorbereitet dabei
klären sie uns doch noch mal ganz kurz
die genese dieser entscheidung die aus
russland kommt was gibt es dafür gründe
und warum eigentlich jetzt so plötzlich
und erst jetzt
ja also man kriegt ja auch immer nur die
information für über die medien und da
heißt es jetzt dass russland sagt es
fehlende gas verdichter teile angebliche
von siemens das muss man jetzt mal
abwarten ob es sich tatsächlich
bestätigt oder ob sie mir ist das auch
so bestätigt so dass eben das gas nicht
ein gesteigen fließen kann in die
pipeline dass es wohl offensichtlich der
grund der hier genannt wird man weiß
aber natürlich nicht ob das so stimmt
und ob das nicht vielleicht vorgeschoben
ist denn russland selber könnte ja
durchaus auch gas liefern wenn ich
überall aus dem 1 dann über die
polnische pipeline über ja mal also auch
da sind die lieferung her schon länger
gedrosselt also wenn russland wollte
könnte es der gas liefern moment sieht
es aber so aus als wenn es nicht will
lassen sie uns zum abschluss noch mal
ganz schnell über alternativen sprechen
sie sagten noch sind die speicher vor
wir müssen uns keine sorgen machen aber
was passiert dann zum ende des jahres
sind ja im moment ist ja so dass 40
prozent der fehlen das heißt man wird
vermutlich die speicher langsamer füllen
aber es kommt ja noch gas das ist ja mal
die gute nachricht aber wir haben auch
alternativen wir können natürlich auch
auf andere länder ausweichen wichtig ist
jetzt in der tat dass man die speicher
wie geplant die sollen ja bis zum ersten
oktober dann zu 80 prozent auch gefüllt
sein derzeit sind 55 prozent das kann
man durchaus schaffen aber wichtig ist
in der tat dass wir uns auch vorbereiten
das kann auch sein dass die gaslieferung
ganz gedrosselt werden das wissen wir
nicht was russland macht insofern muss
man darauf vorbereitet seien aus anderen
ländern gas zu bekommen ein zu speichern
also mehr die speicher noch zu füllen
und das andere ist dass man weniger auf
gesetze im im winter und da ist noch
mehr notwendig als die bundesregierung
jetzt macht frau kämpfer besten dank für
ihre einschätzungen danke ihnen und
wir sprechen darüber jetzt weiter mit
unserem bild journalisten und
wirtschaftsexperten johannes
bockenheimer johannes kann es denn sein
dass das nur der erste schritt ist und
daß rußland und uns bald komplett den
gashahn zu ich habe tatsächlich die
befürchtung dass wir da noch mit mehr
rechnen müssten nächsten tagen also
schon bemerkenswert dass das jetzt
passiert ist
wir haben uns in den vergangenen wochen
hatten wir schon bei anderen ländern
gesehen beispielsweise bei bulgarien in
polen niederlanden da hat russland auch
von einem tag auf den anderen tag gesagt
schluss stopp wir liefern nicht mehr und
jetzt wird mit einem ich fürchte
vorgeschobenen argument gesagt wir
können weiter wir können wir müssen
unsere lieferungen an euch am stock und
ich hatte vorhin beispielsweise bei
siemens angerufen und nachgefragt und
was ist denn da los und man ja nie
reparieren und die reaktionen die ich
von siemens jedenfalls bekam war erst
mal von einem pressesprecher mit dem
sprach war einschalten das lächeln oder
lachen viel mehr an es scheint nicht so
momentan dass es wirklich verspätung bei
den reparaturen gibt sondern scheint
tatsächlich so meine vermutung ein
vorgeschobenes argument von den russen
zu sein jetzt nicht mehr weiter liefern
zu wollen also kurz wo ich auch den
punkt hier bei uns also der krieg putin
exakt schuld also er zieht jetzt quasi
konsequenzen ganz genau also ich denke
schon dass das eine politische
entscheidung war und keine technische
entscheidung in dem sondern
das dass da irgendetwas technisch nicht
funktionieren konnte also er setzt diese
gaspipeline eindeutig gegen uns als
kriegsmittel ein und das ist auch
nachvollziehbar wenn man wenn man sich
beispielsweise die quantitäten anschaut
die durch diese rohre gepumpt werden man
muss wissen da laufen jedes jahr 60
milliarden kubikmeter gas durch die
leitung nur um den vergleich zu bringen
damit werden roundabout um die 26
millionen haushalte können damit
befeuert werden das bedeutet dass es
mehr als die hälfte davon von ganz
deutschland also diese pipeline ist ganz
entscheidend für unsere gasversorgung
die verbraucher schlagen natürlich jetzt
die hände über dem kopf zusammen bei
diesen meldungen also die speicher sind
ja wohl noch ganz gut gefüllt aber das
heißt natürlich trotzdem dass die preise
weiterhin steigen und steigen wer soll
das alles bezahlen das ist richtig also
für die kurze zeit das ist natürlich
nicht so dass wir das hier unter unter
unter einschränkungen leiden müssten
also die speicher sind momentan so
gefüllt dass selbst wenn bus russland
heute komplett stoppen würde hätten wir
noch in etwa so 88 tage zeit um volk
vollständig versorgt zu sein die frage
ist aber was passiert im nächsten winter
und die frage ist kann robert habeck es
schaffen bis dahin tatsächlich uns
unabhängig zu machen vom russischen gas
es ist ihm tatsächlich schon gelungen
innerhalb von kürzester zeit die
abhängigkeit von russland
bemerkenswerter weise von 55 auf 35
prozent zu senken aber das reicht noch
nicht aus wir müssen wirklich unabhängig
werden von russland und ja die nächsten
wochen und monate werden zeigen ob
robert habeck das schaffen wird